[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
Bienvenue c'est sens public et c'est
parti pour 90 minutes de débats de
reportage et d'expertise donner du sens
à l'actualité vous proposez des clés de
compréhension des mutations de notre
société vous le savez c'est le Light
motif de cette émission et voici le
sommaire de ce 6 juin 6 juin à la date
était très attendu par les opposants à
la réforme des retraites et la
mobilisation n'est pas au renvoyée des
revues c'est la plus faible depuis le
début du conflit il y a 5 mois quelle
sera la stratégie de l'intersyndicale
dans les prochains jours la retraite à
64 ans commencera-t-elle à s'appliquer
au mois de septembre comme prévu et puis
cette proposition de loi du groupe
liotte qui doit être examiné jeudi à
l'Assemblée à tel donné de faux espoirs
aux Français hostiles à la réforme on
répond à toutes ces questions dans une
minute et puis pour notre débat de
société je vous emmène au Danemark ou la
politique migratoire très stricte fait
l'objet d'un large consensus politique
il y a un consensus clair au Parlement
pour des politiques strictes sur
l'immigration et aussi dans l'opinion
publique danoise cette ligne dure n'est
plus vraiment débattue c'est quelque
chose de vraiment consensuel dans la
politique danoisette
contrôle des frontières plan anti ghetto
expulsion de réfugiés conditions durci
pour obtenir la nationalité ce modèle
danois porté aujourd'hui par un
gouvernement de gauche social-démocrate
dans le pays et bien peut-il s'appliquer
en France comme le souhaite le parti LR
en confronte les arguments de nos
experts et invités politiques dans trois
quarts d'heure mais d'abord notre
reportage au cœur de la 14e
manifestation parisienne contre la
réforme des retraites avec Audrey wettaz
à Bordeaux en haut à gauche Rennes Paris
ou Marseille ils étaient plusieurs
centaines de milliers de manifestants
encore dans la rue beaucoup moins que
lors des précédentes journées de
mobilisation mais toujours là pour
dénoncer une réforme des retraites
injuste selon eux
on est en colère contre
monsieur on sait que au bout du chemin
ça reste sombre beaucoup le concède
maintenant que la loi est promulguée
cette manifestation est peut-être l'une
des dernières sur le sujet des retraites
mais dans le cortège les griefs sont
encore nombreux il y a la réforme des
retraites mais il y a aussi les jeunes
l'éducation les salaires c'est pas réglé
le chômage c'est pas réglé ils ont beau
le dire ça baisse ouais mais ça va
remonter derrière pour l'Inter syndical
c'est aussi l'occasion de se compter
pour peser dans les négociations futures
le sens de cette mobilisation c'est
aussi de montrer que sur les futurs
sujets les sujets qui seront mis sur la
table on a eu des bilatérales pour
l'instant on n'a pas d'autres nouvelles
par le par le gouvernement c'est-à-dire
le pouvoir d'achat la question des
salaires la question des conditions de
travail des organisations de travail du
dialogue social de la du respect des
travailleurs dans la transition ou dans
les transitions et transformations en
cours écologiques et numérique on va
être là on sera là et on est là
question pour nous que on nous impose
encore un agenda régressif et qu'on nous
dise très bien on va discuter sur la
conditionnalité du RSA une conférence de
presse devant l'Assemblée nationale
comme un symbole jeudi la proposition de
loi du groupe lot pour abroger la
réforme il sera étudié même si le texte
devrait être vidé de sa substance les
manifestants espèrent au moins un vote
symbolique je vous présente tout de
suite mes invités pour débattre faire le
bilan de cette mobilisation Christelle
krappelet bonsoir bienvenue directrice
de BVA opinion Jean-Marie Pernot bonsoir
bonsoir bienvenue à vous aussi vous êtes
politologue chercheur associé à
l'Institut de recherche économique et
social et auteur de ce livre le
syndicalisme d'après publié aux éditions
Le Détour Sophie davinel bonsoir et
bienvenue grand reporter au service
politique du Figaro et j'accueille
Laetitia cruppa Laetitia drupa ça me
fait très plaisir que vous soyez avec
nous sur ce plateau et en plateforme
bienvenue welcome back allez on commence
on fait le bilan le bilan de cette
journée peut-être aussi le bilan de la
mobilisation parce que voilà on peut se
demander avec la faible mobilisation du
jour si c'est pas la dernière journée on
verra bien Christelle craquelais vous
dites quoi les Français finalement ils
sont en train d'intérioriser la réforme
des retraites le fait que bon bah va
falloir y aller à 64 ans une forme de
capitalisme qui s'exprime sur le fond
ils ont pas tellement changé ils sont
toujours très largement opposés à la
réforme c'est pas parce qu'elle est
passée que tout d'un coup ils sont pour
mais ils vont pas mais ils vont moins
manifester une forme de deux fatalisme
qui s'exprime la loi elle est passée
elle va probablement s'appliquer et donc
sans doute que pour certains ça ne vaut
pas vraiment la peine de continuer à se
battre sur ce front et peut-être qu'il
faut voilà se battre sur d'autres fronts
mais l'amertume quand même je pense
reste assez fort ça c'est un des thèmes
qui sera très intéressant notamment
politiquement à analyser les espèces de
réplique pour employer un terme de de
tectonique des plaques de de ce
mouvement juste donner un sondage
tolunaris interactif pour RTL et avef
info 60 % des Français qui disent encore
aujourd'hui qui sont défavorables et
40%, ça monte un petit peu de Français
favorable à la à la réforme des
retraites ça veut dire qu'il y a une
toute petite partie de l'opinion qui qui
bascule un peu est-ce qu'on peut dire ça
à peine ou peut-être que c'est les
personnes qui était sur le fond pas
vraiment hostile à la réforme mais qui
se demandait si c'était le bon moment si
ça n'allait pas embraser le pays qu'il a
se disent bon bah finalement c'est passé
je contestait pas énormément sur le fond
je suis revenu un petit peu à une forme
d'adhésion je suis pas sûr que les plus
opposés et basculé c'était plus les
indécisants avec vous le match est
terminé c'est l'une des phrases du jour
de Laurent Berger le secrétaire national
de la CFDT Jean-Marie Pernaut est-ce que
c'est forcément la fin du mouvement de
contestation à laquelle on a assisté
aujourd'hui non je pense pas bon c'est
sûr on est à une séquence là qui vient
d'être passé ce mouvement il sans doute
le dernier dans l'objectif était sur les
retraites il a été entretenu jusqu'au
bout par l'affaire du dépôt de la loi
Diotte ok ce qui s'est un petit peu
dégonflé ces derniers jours même donc il
y a aussi cet ange là qui avait un petit
peu disparu et qui a du concourir à ce
que les gens se déplacent moins ce qui
fera penser ce que ce que vous disiez
quand même et on le voit dans votre
reportage c'est que en fait depuis très
longtemps il y a des gens qui croient
que la réforme de boule ne bougera pas
mais il venait quand même aux
manifestations c'est toujours ce slogan
on est là on est là qui revient et je
pense qu'il y a aussi
on est là pour marquer justement que
même si la décision est prise et bien on
veut se faire respecter c'est une forme
de dignité qui fait que les gens
d'ailleurs c'est le ressort de beaucoup
de conflits sociaux la reconnaissance
qu'on dit des êtres humains qu'on n'est
pas des rien du tout et que même s'il
pouvoir politique se permet de prendre
des oucases et bien le peuple enfin le
peuple les gens se vivent comme ça mais
ils étaient assez nombreux dans la rue
pour qu'on dise tout de même qu'ils sont
une bonne part de l'expression populaire
surtout adossé à des sondages comme cela
donc ceux qui portait ce refus et que et
bien même si on sait très bien que la
réforme sera se déroulera on défendra la
dignité du travailleur qui ne se laisse
pas faire elle est fait politique les
faits sur notre démocratie on en
reparlera évidemment dans ce débat se
fait de Ravinel le gouvernement est
d'ailleurs il le fait pas il aurait tort
de place trôner
ce soir parce que voilà c'est ce que je
disais ce bras de fer il va laisser
forcément des traces électorales aussi
oui évidemment espace électorale même si
et non effectivement des traces
électorales même si elles sont encore
difficiles à déterminer sous quelle
forme elle s'exprimeont il ne place
Trump pas aussi parce que il veut
effectivement récupérer une part de ceux
qui s'interrogeaient ces indécis qui
avaient une hésitation sur le fond
évidemment qui ne cherche pas à
convaincre ceux qui sont opposés mais il
sait aussi que la situation tout de même
est reste bouillonnante et que si une
séquence comme vous le dites très
justement est terminée la colère sociale
comme on le voit dans les études
d'opinion reste importante elle reste
importante et en particulier sur la
question du pouvoir d'achat et on ne
sait pas quand on interroge l'opposition
de gauche il le distrait clairement
l'objectif
et le distrait clairement indirectement
l'objectif n'est plus tant le seul
dossier des retraites que de maintenir
cette tension sociale pour pouvoir
reprendre d'autres cortèges sur d'autres
thèmes dans dans les mois qui viennent
et on verra si à l'espace pour ça
autredage qui est tombé là en cette fin
d'après-midi sur la côte les côtes de
popularité de duo de l'exécutif il faut
Fiducial pour Paris Match et SUD RADIO
on a un Emmanuel Macron qui grimpe de
deux points à 31% à l'inverse une
Élisabeth borne qui décroche de 4 points
à 26% Christelle Crapelet s au-delà
au-delà de du binôme Macron borne est-ce
qu'il y a des personnalités puisqu'on
est un peu dans le bilan ce soir est-ce
qu'il y a des personnalités politiques
ou syndicales qui sortent gagnantes de
ce droit de faire de ces cinq mois de
faire mais non c'est un peu le souci
c'est que le gouvernement ne sort pas
gagnant mais il y a pas quelqu'un en
face qui incarnerait une de consensus
sur l'opposition alors on a quand même
le rassemblement national qui dans les
dans nos enquêtes apparaissaient quand
même comme assez gagnant de la séquence
toute en s'étend assez peu exprimé mais
il engrangeait un peu sur la colère sur
sur le rejet les organisations
syndicales ont vu leur image se redorer
mais finalement sans obtenir vraiment
quelque chose donc ce serait à
poursuivre pour voir voilà comment elles
vont être perçues dans l'opinion et puis
à gauche on n'a pas encore vraiment un
leader qui fait consensus il y a
beaucoup quand même de d'oppositions
donc il manque voilà une force
d'opposition qui fasse voilà qui
recueille une majorité pour faire
basculer et entre guillemets renverser
le gouvernement dans d'autres élections
est-ce que la fermeté d'Emmanuel Macron
elle peut séduire quand même une partie
de son on dit on parle souvent du socle
électoral mais au-delà de son électoral
celui de la de la droite on va dire
traditionnelle ou parlementaire c'est
son pari c'est évidemment son pari et
c'est assez impressionnant de voir c'est
impressionnant du point de vue de
l'opposition parce que comme vous le
disiez très justement ils sont aussi un
petit peu lassés d'avoir un mur grâce à
eux et c'est la force d'Emmanuel Macron
c'est une forme de de disons de de
permanence d'attitude depuis la première
mobilisation en janvier on se souvient
qu'il a été souvent absent souvent
présent en France mais engagé sur
d'autres sujets là hier il était au
moins Saint-Michel sur une question de
permanence de l'histoire et de vision de
très très loin pour justement enjamber
et se débat sur les retraites et donc il
donne le sentiment de ne pas écouter
cette colère sociale mais il donne aussi
le sentiment d'une permanence dans sa
décision je l'avais promis c'était dans
ma campagne présidentielle je l'ai mené
jusqu'au bout évidemment que ça peut
séduire d'autant qu'il a publié des
décrets dimanche des décrets
d'applications de cette loi donc
vraiment ça détermination ça peut
séduire évidemment une partie de son
socle et qui commençait un petit peu à
s'interroger revenir peut-être vers une
sociale démocratie et évidemment sa
première sa première cible qui est du
fait
des sondages qui marquent le basculement
à droite qui est cette droite
républicaine qui ne souhaite pas
d'alliance avec le rassemblement
national Jean-Marc Pernaut c'est souvent
vous êtes venu plusieurs fois nous nous
éclairer de votre connaissance du de
l'histoire et du monde syndical sur ce
plateau mais on s'est souvent dit
s'il en ressort rien ou pas de victoire
ce sera quand même problématique pour
pour les syndicats et même en affichant
une union aussi forte et inédite depuis
très très longtemps c'est est-ce que il
est arrivé dans notre histoire que un
mouvement
syndical hostile à une réforme de
retraite finisse par obtenir le retrait
de la dit très fort non en 95 le
mouvement a été assez puissant adossé à
des grèves importantes qui ont un peu
manqué dans le conflit récent et ils ont
obtenu le retrait de la des réformes des
régimes spéciaux qui étaient prévus à
l'époque notamment notamment chez les
cheminots mais globalement toutes les
mobilisations sur les retraites ce sont
heurtées à ce mur ce qui a contribué
bien sûr ça a contribué à la
désaffection tendentielle à l'égard des
syndicats et cette fois-ci
paradoxalement je pense pas que ça ait
exactement le même effet parce qu'en
fait il y a un nouvel acteur syndical
qui est les Français connaissent les
syndicats mais là il y a un nouvel
acteur qui est né qui s'appelle
l'intersyndicale et ça ils connaissent
pas par contre dans notre pays c'est pas
une tradition c'est rare il y a eu des
accords inter syndicaux dans les
conflits récents mais déjà on a eu
l'impression de quelque chose d'un peu
plus dense une inter syndicale les
porte-paroles c'était pas celui de la
CGT de la CFDT c'était le porte-parole
de l'intersyndicale et ça le reste après
4 mois malgré parce que Laurent Berger
est quand même la figure qui ressortie
de cette interse syndicale et ce matin
sur Europe 1 il se félicitait d'avoir
gagné 43000 adhérents en 2023 ils
disaient que c'était un nombre qu'il
n'avaient jamais atteint avant et donc
il dit lui que la CFDT a gagné des
adhésions parce que les gens plutôt
quittaient les syndicats avancent
mouvement et alors ça aurait fait un
mouvement de balancier inverse donc
peut-être que la sfdt sera la grande
gagnante avec
ce que je disais je pense malgré oui
le reste la figure qui va rester parce
que le succès de la CFDT est lié
justement à son rôle dans
l'intersyndicale n'oubliez pas que c'est
le premier syndicat de France en terme
de nombre d'électeurs et en termes de
nombre d'adhérents donc elle a joué ce
rôle fédérateur qui
ils auraient peut-être
grappiller ou rafler j'ai pas le thème
moins d'adhérence ils avaient fait
cavalier seul dans un con dans un centre
c'est absolument certain ils ont profité
du cas aussi ils vont gagner la CFDT et
l'organisation la mieux implantée sur le
territoire c'est aussi pour ça que c'est
elle qui engrange parce qu'on engrange
en général là où on est la CFD la CGT
revendique aussi une trentaine de
milliers d'adhérents oui mais bon ça il
faudrait
la question c'est savoir s'ils vont les
garder et puis 33000 ou 43000 qu'est-ce
que c'est d'ailleurs il y a 19 millions
de salariés dans le privé 5 millions
dans le public donc bon la question elle
est pas là la question c'est est-ce que
ce qu'ils ont gagné en légitimité parce
que quand même très clairement dans ce
mouvement et c'est pour ça que je dis
que les faits sera peut-être pas comme
les autres fois certes c'est un échec
puisque l'objectif n'est pas atteint
mais tout de même la responsabilité la
légitimité pour beaucoup de gens aller
de leur côté alors ça elles se sont
heurtées effectivement à un mur les murs
ça peut séduire mais le jour où
s'effondre ça ça laisse des ça laisse
des traces et je pense que l'enjeu pour
eux aujourd'hui c'est certes chacun va
développer ses logiques ça ne l'Inter
syndicale n'annule pas les différences
d'approche qui entre les syndicats mais
c'est comment ils vont pouvoir nourrir
cette intercer syndicale au sommet
est-ce qu'elle va durer bah écoutez
là-dessus on n'en sait rien du tout en
tout cas l'intention est affiché ce
qu'on parle de la CGT de la CFDT bien
sûr c'est les plus importantes mais vous
avez aussi là dedans l'une ça la CFTC
etc c'est pas solidaire c'est pas des
syndicats la CGC c'est pas tous des
syndicats radicaux etc
ni ayant le goût de travailler ensemble
ça va être un vrai défi vous avez raison
et je crois que c'est une des questions
mais curieusement on n'a pas vu beaucoup
de lézards pour l'instant et ils
envisagent ils travaillent d'ailleurs
sur des dossiers ensemble il avait fait
un peu avant sur l'assurance chômage
tout ne vient pas de là je pense que il
y a une antériorité à ce qui s'est passé
là la réforme de retraite on l'avait
déjà vu ces rapprochements mais là je
pense que l'image qu'ils ont acquis fait
que l'enjeu il est là au niveau de
l'Inter syndicale nationale il y a aussi
des enjeux au niveau local évidemment et
d'autres combats à venir mais je
voudrais qu'on reste un peu focus
concentré sur cette réforme des
retraites et grâce à Quentin calmer on
va se poser la question des décrets
d'application vous l'évoquez Sophie de
Ravinel bonsoir Quentin bonsoir à tous
ils ont donc été publiés ces deux
premiers décrets au Journal officiel
c'était dimanche dernier voilà deux
premiers décrets sur un total de 31 qui
doivent être publiés d'ici à la fin du
mois d'août les deux premiers décrets
visent à appliquer les articles 10 et 11
de la réforme des retraites qui
désormais s'appelle la loi du 14 avril
2023 il va falloir mémoriser ça oui en
fait c'est tout simplement la date de
promulgation de la loi par le Président
de la République le premier décret porte
sur la mesure d'âge et le passage de
l'âge de départ de 62 à 64 ans deuxième
décret il concerne les départs anticipés
pour les carrières longues avec de
nouvelles bornes d'âge en fonction de
votre début de cotisation à pèse 18 20
ou 21 ans vous le voyez vous pourrez
partir à la retraite respectivement à 58
60 62 63 ans dans un communiqué le
ministre du Travail explique la réforme
des retraites s'appliquera à partir du
1er septembre conformément à la loi du
14 avril 2023 il engagement du Président
de la République alors qu'il faudra-t-il
consulter et bien la prochaine étape
effectivement Thomas il faudra d'abord
consulter les conseils d'administration
des caisses de la Sécurité sociale mais
Renaud Villars le directeur général de
la Caisse nationale d'assurance
vieillesse il a déjà annoncé qu'il
serait prêt au 1er septembre et que quoi
qu'il arrive d'ailleurs Thomas la
réforme elle rentrera bien en vigueur ce
premier septembre même si la proposition
de loi liotte serait à était adopté
jeudi en première lecture à l'Assemblée
nationale écoutez-le
cette proposition de loi d'ailleurs peut
introduire presque une forme
d'incompréhension sur les assurés si
elle devait être adoptée en première
lecture à l'Assemblée elle n'aurait
aucun effet sur la réforme actuellement
en vigueur en revanche les assurés se
dirait ah mais j'ai entendu sur France
Info ça y est ça a été abrogé ça crée
beaucoup de confusion alors qu'en
réalité ça ne changera pas les règles du
jeu au premier septembre et on risque
d'avoir pas mal d'assurés qui nous
appelle en disant mais je comprends pas
normalement je dois partir comme prévu à
c'est bien une adoption même s'il y a
une adoption ce serait une adoption que
à l'Assemblée nationale il faudrait que
ensuite le texte soit adopté au Sénat et
on le sait c'est très peu probable vu
que ici la majorité elle est en faveur
de la réforme donc tout porte à croire
que la réforme va bien entrer en vigueur
au 1er septembre même si on le rappelle
Thomas la réforme elle va se faire
progressivement à raison d'un décalage
de l'âge de départ de trois mois par
génération pour les personnes nées à
partir du 1er septembre 1961 là je
l'égal de départ sont quatre ans
concernera les générations
sortir de celle née en 1968 dernier info
sur le nombre de trimestres requis
celui-ci sera de 172 ce sont les
fameuses 43 annuités dès la génération
1965 merci beaucoup Quentin bon je suis
de la génération 66 je m'étais dit tant
que c'est pas terminé je vais pas
regarder là je vais quand même aller
regarder ce que ça change pour moi
Sophie davinel je voudrais qu'on
s'intéresse quand même à ce cette
proposition de loi déposée par le groupe
liote à l'Assemblée donc qui a été en
grande partie vidée de de sa substance
je disais non mais titres est-ce qu'ils
ont pas joué avec l'espoir des Français
et des Français hostiles à la réforme
quand même pour peu que les uns que les
Français s'intéressent vraiment à ce qui
se passe au coeur au centre de
l'Assemblée nationale peut-être mais je
pense qu'ils ont voulu jouer toutes les
cartouches qu'il pouvait jouer jusqu'à
la fin toutes les cartouches
parlementaires et répondre d'une
certaine façon
c'est obstruction contre-obstruction et
c'est vrai que là on assiste tout de
même
spécialiste de du fonctionnement de
l'Assemblée nationale sont un peu
surpris à des pratiques qui ne sont pas
habituelles et on peut le voir notamment
avec
il y a elbron Pivet la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale donc de la couleur
de la majorité présidentielle qui
pourrait décréter y recevable les
amendements de la proposition de loi
Eliott sont tenir compte de la vie du
président de la commission donc Eric
Coquerel évidemment c'est un instruire
et il est insoumis il y est opposé mais
enfin tout de même il y a une tradition
de respect de la vie même si elle peut
absolument passer outre les uns et les
autres c'est ce que vous dit à se
renvoie la responsabilité ou
l'inconstitutionnalité de leur démarche
quoi oui je pense qu'il faudra des
spécialistes encore des disons des
historiens qui regarderont ça avec un
peu de distance aujourd'hui ce que les
Français peuvent se dire c'est que
chacun piétine les règles de la
démocratie les règles de l'Assemblée
nationale je ne sais pas si c'est une
bonne chose pour le fonctionnement de
notre démocratie de façon générale et
pour revenir sur ce que nous disions
précédemment concernant le chef de
l'État Emmanuel Macron il faudra étudier
il faudra voir si ça façon de faire ne
vient pas encore un peu griffer la
confiance que les Français peuvent avoir
dans le fonctionnement et dans les
méthodes de des partis politiques et
globalement de la démocratie alors sur
cette proposition de loi du groupe lyode
je vous propose un élément cet
après-midi début d'après-midi on est à
l'Assemblée nationale et le président du
groupe lyaute s'appelle Bertrand penché
s'adresse à la première ministre
je voulais vous rappeler l'article 3 de
notre Constitution la souveraineté
appartient au peuple français qui la
délègue à ses représentants nous les
députés ainsi que l'article 24 le
Parlement vote les lois nous votons les
lois le général de Gaulle expliqué que
notre Constitution c'est des
institutions une pratique vous ne
respectez pas ces bonnes pratiques vous
ne respectez même pas le père de la
Cinquième République la démocratie est
notre bien le plus précieux notre groupe
est de nombreux autres députés sur nos
bancs veulent la préserver madame la
Première ministre quand allez-vous
apaiser notre pays en laissant enfin les
députés voter la loi
alors nous ça nous passionne évidemment
je pense que ça intéresse aussi beaucoup
les téléspectateurs de Public Sénat et
de sciences publiques qui sont férus
d'actualité parlementaires mais est-ce
que ça passe pas un peu au dessus des
radars de la majorité des français quand
même pris c'est le trap et cette
histoire de proposition de loi liotes
votée pas voté etc sans doute un peu
surtout que ça a été placé sur
un
ionnel qui pour beaucoup voilà leur
échappe ça aurait pu quand même
fonctionner en réactivant une forme
d'espoir que voilà on revienne en
arrière très vite finalement le
gouvernement a déplacé un peu le débat
et on en est arrivé à des discussions
sur est-ce que c'est constitutionnel
est-ce que c'est la tradition donc je
pense que
la journée d'action elle a été calée
aujourd'hui deux jours avant le l'examen
du de cette proposition liotte à
l'Assemblée mais finalement c'est un peu
retombé parce que finalement la petite
musique qui a circulé c'est que ça ne
serait pas voté que finalement ça ne
servirait pas et la question était juste
et ce qu'il respecte les règles et du
coup là où je rebondis un peu sur ce que
vous disiez c'est que sur sur le fond
voilà je pense pas que ça ait beaucoup
changé les choses en revanche ça donne
quand même l'Image de quelque chose de
confus et effectivement ben peut-être
une absence de respect des règles que ce
n'est plus clair et je pense
qu'effectivement ça peut contribuer à
renforcer le rejet quand même très fort
chez les Français du système
démocratique du fonctionnement de
l'Assemblée nationale et ça ça peut être
un peu inquiétant de effectivement ça
pose une question démocratique on
pourrait je l'évoquer parler de fausses
promesses Laetitia selon vous les
leaders syndicaux et politiques ont
animé ce mouvement et qui continue de le
faire alors qu'ils savent que la réforme
des retraites est en train d'être
adoptée vous dites qu'ils ont une
responsabilité dans le délitement
démocratique oui ils ont une
responsabilité depuis le 19 janvier ça a
commencé le 19 janvier ce mouvement et
dans les médias ce matin on en est donc
à la 14e journée de mobilisation les
responsables syndicaux et les politiques
ont continué à répéter les mêmes
messages qui sont devenus des mantras je
suis sûr qu'on arrête n'importe qui dans
la rue ils pourront dire mépris du
peuple et puis aussi déni démocratique
ces messages ont été répétés en boucle
depuis plus de depuis 5 mois on va dire
et bien écoutez ce matin encore on avait
ces messages je vous propose d'écouter
deux personnes opposées politiquement
Aurélien Pradier député LR du lot et
Anne Hidalgo mer socialiste de Paris
l'un sur LCI l'autre sur France Inter ce
matin quasiment en même temps écoutez
remettons-nous un peu les idées au clair
je le redis ce texte là aujourd'hui le
sujet de cette semaine à l'Assemblée
nationale n'est pas tant les 60 62 ou 64
ans le sujet c'est le rapport à notre
démocratie je pense que ce texte là
parce qu'il a été adopté dans des
conditions épouvantables et un texte
empoisonné pour notre démocratie il y a
une volonté de quelques-uns de
quelques-uns très puissants avec des
intérêts économiques très puissants de
tout prendre ils sont dans une prédation
totale des ressources de la planète de
l'exploitation humaine et en plus
aujourd'hui la démocratie est
complètement inexistante je vous le
redis c'est très grave ce qui se passe
bon l'argument du déni démocratique côté
politique et côté syndical côté syndical
c'est exactement les mêmes arguments va
prendre l'exemple de Laurent Berger
parce que il n'a eu de cesse d'opposer
dans toutes ces interviews le politique
et le social il disait à chaque fois à
chaque question journaliste oui mais le
social va contre le politique et le
politique va contre le social alors lui
à Jeanne me demander mais enfin
expliciter qu'est-ce que ça veut dire le
politique et social de social et
politique qu'est-ce qu'il voulait dire
Laurent Berger exactement la même chose
qu'anidalgo à l'instant les puissants
les gouvernants versus le peuple et ce
peuple que beaucoup ont eu du mal quand
même à définir avec un même constat
qu'on retrouve d'une responsabilité de
l'exécutif on a commencé à l'évoquer sur
ce plateau et savoir lancer le débat
mais ils ont raison Emmanuel Macron et
le gouvernement ont leur part de
responsabilité et non pas réussi à faire
le pont avec les Français n'ont pas
réussi à tendre la main en français ils
n'ont pas réussi à établir un dialogue
avec le français ils n'ont pas réussi à
fédérer autour de cette réforme donc
bien sûr qu'ils sont responsables de
leur image de déconnexion mais la petite
musique que l'on entend celle de Denis
une démocratie de on vous mettrez ça
fait depuis quatre mois plus de quatre
mois ça a été amplifié par les
haut-parleurs médiatiques cette petite
musique Thomas c'est un danger pour la
démocratie pourquoi à cause de un climat
d'inquiétude oui et plus que
l'inquiétude et la colère Laurent Berger
vient de sortir un livre du mépris à la
colère plus que la colère on est dans le
ressentiment c'est le ressentiment que
ressent la France là en ce moment depuis
plusieurs mois j'ai contacté plusieurs
sondeurs ce matin pour savoir prendre un
peu le pouls vous savez de justement de
l'opinion publique tous m'ont dit pour
le moment c'est le déni démocratie c'est
pas du tout un thème qui est retenu
parce que il est pas très compréhensible
et qu'il est encore un peu trop abstrait
mais le mépris Thomas Le Mépris a été
vraiment c'est une majorité de Français
qui à chaque fois qu'on leur pose la
question naturellement dit oui le
gouvernement nous méprise et c'est là le
plus grand danger vous faites référence
au jour sombre de notre histoire en
conclut là dessus exactement je fais
référence et j'ose faire référence bien
sûr
départ aux naissances des registres des
régimes fascistes et totalitaires dans
le 20e siècle il faudrait que tout ce
qu'on vraiment qu'on rouvre nos livres
d'histoire ils sont tous nés de cette
opposition stérile peuple
et élite finalement parce que gouvernant
c'est sa regroupe les élites et puis sur
le ressentiment exacerbé des classes
moyennes et des classes populaires et
plus récemment
même regarder comment Donald Trump s'est
installé à la Maison Blanche en 2016
réécoutez ces mots réétudier sa
propagande et puis RD one également en
Turquie qui a un styliste au régime
autoritaire en se présentant comme
l'incarnation le représentant ce sont
ces mots du petit peuple merci Laetitia
alors je suis sûr que ça va vous faire
réagir autour de ce plateau Jean-Marie
Pernaut je commence avec vous
est-ce que on s'est dit tout à l'heure
mais finalement un mouvement rares sont
les mouvements sociaux qui ont réussi à
faire céder un gouvernement sur la
réforme des retrait est-ce que ça veut
dire pour autant qu'il faut pas les
mener hein et deux est-ce que l'Inter
syndicale par son acharnement joue un
rôle dans le de le délit de démocratique
du pays comment réagissez ça rejoint
c'est classéparation entre le social et
le politique elle est difficile à tracer
c'est évident que la question des
retraites c'est une question éminemment
politique d'ailleurs elle renvoie à
d'autres questions la question du
travail pourquoi et au fond est-ce que
les gens ont hâte de quitter le travail
bah allons voir un petit peu comment les
gens travaillent dans oui parce que vous
savez la source du ressentiment n'est
pas elle est pas seulement
issue du discours politique ou syndical
elle est aussi dans les conditions de
vie des gens le ressentiment c'est aussi
ce qu'ils vivent tous les jours on a un
taux d'inflation qui est brandi pour
justifier que le SMIC augmente de 3 4 %
parce qu'il y a indexé sur le taux
d'inflation le taux d'inflation c'est
pas le coup de la vie même ligne c'est
Élodie le panier le cou de la vie a
beaucoup plus augmenté que ça vous avez
aujourd'hui 16 millions de personnes qui
ont du mal à nourrir leur famille le
ressentiment il vient d'abord de là le
discours du politique vous savez quand
il faut boucler son budget et donner à
manger à ses gosses c'est relativement
secondaire du politique qui est
complètement branché sur ce que vous
avez quand même un responsable politique
qui dit mais de toute façon le vote du
Parlement n'a aucune importance même
s'il Parlement votre contre la loi elle
sera appliquée vous croyez pas que ça
aurait quand même une incidence sur la
façon dont les gens revoient ce qu'est
vous croyez complète pour la
participation électorale aux élections
législatives avec un discours on nous
dit très clairement le Parlement ne sert
à rien on élit un César tous les quatre
ans et il fait ce qu'il a envie de faire
donc moi je crois que le danger il est
là c'est la perception massive qu'on a
que finalement c'est quoi les pouvoirs
interminants quand même une constitution
démocratique c'est celle qui assure tes
contre-pouvoirs au pouvoir on sait ça
depuis Montesquieu voir Machiavel on
s'aperçoit là que il n'y a aucun
contre-pouvoir dans notre Constitution
on nous sort des astuces de tous les
côtés ce que vous disiez tout à l'heure
et que finalement
légal et la légalité veut dire que le
Parlement n'a strictement aucune
importance dans ce pays et ça pose
effectivement si vous voulez excusez-moi
sur la perception de la démocratie je
trouve que c'est quand même un peu plus
un problème que le discours des
dirigeants syndicaux Sophie Ravinel
notre démocratie elle peut difficilement
faire un autre constat que elle sort
affaiblie de ces 5 mois est-ce que vous
dites ça vous aussi oui je dirais ça
peut-être que il faut entendre aussi les
nuances au sein de la gauche
relativement à cela et se méfier des
excès des uns et les autres disons que
dans la stratégie
[Musique]
à titre personnel moi je je vous rejoins
sur la question de l'abstention et je
suis très inquiète de cela y compris
pour la suite sur la stratégie si l'on
considère qu'effectivement Emmanuel
Macron agit d'une façon qui va à
l'encontre des intérêts de la démocratie
est-ce que
la meilleure disons stratégique c'est
d'aller frontalement contre lui à la
façon d'un Jean-Luc Mélenchon je les
écoutais tous les deux il y a deux trois
heures dans la rue Jean-Luc Mélenchon
avenue de Tourville et Carole delgal
présidente de la région Occitanie
la rue de Grenelle socialiste ils ont un
discours très différent c'est à dire que
Jean-Luc Mélenchon juge que Emmanuel
Macron est vraiment l'assassin de la
démocratie avec des termes très lourds
très durs Carole Delga dit non le danger
pour la démocratie c'est l'extrême
droite Jean-Luc mélange Emmanuel Macron
lui est dans un déni de l'attention au
peuple et effectivement c'est ce rapport
au RN que moi me semble intéressant dans
cette échiquier parce qu'on en parle
très peu au final du RN ce matin dans
toutes les interviews tous ont dit c'est
le RM qui RN qui va sortir gagnant tout
je l'ignore
mais écoutez réécouter les interviews
donc ils sont tous les mêmes après
est-ce que c'est aussi une stratégie de
leur part de faire monter le
rassemblement national on verra bien ce
que disent les enquêtes d'opinion de
fait on voit bien qu'elles vont vers
cette dynamique qui est associée une
partie de la droite au rassemblement
national et donc aussi bien dans les
idées on voit bien l'interview d'Édouard
Philippe donc l'ancien Premier ministre
qui lui s'est exprimé de façon très
forte sur les questions de l'immigration
qui est un des prochains dossiers à
venir il s'est exprimé pourquoi parce
qu'il s'est aussi évidemment
il n'hésite pas à remettre en cause
l'article de 1968 sur la question du
rapport à l'immigration des Algériens
avec la France mais aussi parce qu'il
sent que c'est une dynamique que c'est
une tension qu'il faut lutter contre
et là c'est une dynamique
je ne sais pas en tout cas ce que je
sais c'est qu'ils font un sans faute du
point de vue parlementaire aujourd'hui
et qu'ils n'ont rien à faire pour
engranger et pourtant est-ce que oui ou
non c'est sans doute trop tôt parce que
les prochaines échéances électorales en
septembre ensuite les européennes est-ce
que vous pouvez déjà évaluer le gain
politique éventuel de ces 5 mois de bras
de fer dans lequel effectivement le
rassemblement national est quand même
resté en retrait ils ont pas pris
beaucoup de risques est-ce qu'il y a un
gain politique à attendre pour eux il y
a un gain d'images un cont
estable ce qu'il en gagnant
respectabilité parce qu'ils se sont
totalement sans trop participer mais on
ne remet pas en cause le fait qu'ils
sont au Parlement enfin des choses sur
lesquelles on débattait encore il y a il
y a quelques mois donc il y a un gain
d'image après ce qui est un gain
électoral c'est un peu tôt effectivement
pour le dire leur électorat est aussi un
électorat parfois volatil qui va pas
forcément se mobiliser donc eux aussi
vont être confrontés à ces à ces
questions d'abstention et qui peuvent se
poser
si on croit moins ou plus à la
démocratie est-ce qu'on va plus voter
quand on votre rassemblement national ça
ça va être là l'enjeu et puis je voulais
revenir un peu sur cette crise
démocratique c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
dans nos enquêtes le vote n'est plus la
première manière pour les gens
d'exprimer leur engagement mais ça veut
pas totalement dire qu'ils sont des
engagés qui s'en fichent totalement
quand on leur demande sur
l'environnement par exemple chez les
jeunes mais pour une cause précise et de
façon un peu individualiste c'est-à-dire
ils vont s'engager ponctuellement pour
un sujet les jeunes vont s'engager sur
d'autres thématiques et le social parle
encore beaucoup aux personnes mais c'est
vrai que ça ne s'exprime plus vraiment
par le vote Sophie davinel vous parliez
des deux discours un peu au sein de des
de la nupesse ou de la Nupe avec les
tendances c'est quoi la stratégie
Jean-Luc Mélenchon pour l'année pour
parler de d'inters syndicale parce qu'il
y a l'un des bilans en fait pardon de
l'un des bilans c'est 5 mois c'est c'est
une double union une double unité il y
avait il y avait l'Union syndicale
l'intersac et puis il y avait quand même
les parties de gauche réunis au sein de
la nuque et qui réussissait quand même à
peu près à avoir une stratégie commune
c'est quoi la stratégie de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon aujourd'hui je pense que si
les uns et les autres vous avez les
idées que vous pouvez les apporter je
suis preneuse parce que depuis son
interview à 20 minutes au quotidien 20
Minutes il y a 48 heures dans laquelle
il a véritablement provoqué ces alliés
de la nupesse évidemment en avançant la
possibilité qu'Adrien cadenas qui a été
condamné par la justice pour violence
conjugale puisse être un de ses
successeurs et donc candidats à la
présidentielle premier point agressif et
deuxième point en disant que s'il n'y
avait pas de nups pour les européennes
finalement et bien la disparition de la
nuit pêche serait possible ce qui est
très intéressant c'est à dire que à la
fois on a l'impression qu'il veut casser
la nupaisse parce qu'elle peut-être
parce qu'elle lui échappe peut-être
parce que effectivement au sein de
l'Assemblée nationale elle a une
véritable utilité elle fonctionne en
intergroupe et il y a une unique une
union qui se construit et que ça se fait
sans lui parce qu'il a fait le choix de
ne pas être à l'Assemblée est-ce que il
sent que ça lui échappe parce que
finalement les Européens ils s'en
moquent qui s'en est toujours moqué de
l'enjeu des européennes donc pourquoi
est-ce qu'il fera une fixation là-dessus
et aussi je pense que Jean-Luc Mélenchon
il faut le relire dans le long terme il
a toujours fonctionné de la même façon
avec le Parti de gauche avec le Front de
gauche avec divers autres formations
finalement qu'il a construit depuis sa
sortie du PS et quand elle prenait trop
de place ou qu'elle il risquait de ne
plus avoir à la main il les a
potentiellement remplacé par d'autres et
on pourrait dire aussi en creux que
après un tel mouvement la nuque et elle
est fige aurait pu beaucoup plus
capitaliser sur c'est quand même entre
eux et c'est ce que vous disiez c'est
évidemment un échec déjà à la nups elle
n'a pas permis de gagner quelque chose à
la permis d'éviter une chute qui
semblait irrémédiable des groupes
parlementaires et là on voit vraiment
qu'ils n'ont pas gagné
ont compris ce qui était la nups
des députés LFI à l'Assemblée nationale
a pas toujours été très bien comprises
ou acceptée elle a beaucoup parlé au
coeur de cible et sympathisant à les
filles trouver sa fantastique mais les
autres s'interrogeaient quand même
beaucoup plus et puis il y a quand même
aussi des divergences de fonds ça reste
j'en ai pris Longchamp une personnalité
clivante qui ne fait pas l'unanimité
chez les sympathisants PS les
sympathisants européens écologie et
encore moins quand on parle d'Europe
c'est quand même un vrai sujet de 10% au
premier tour de la présidentielle oui
parce que c'est
les travailleurs ils savent bien que sur
le sujet des retraites avec un décret
duré 64 ans qui est publié ça devient de
plus en plus compliqué
sur le sujet purement des retraites
c'est sans doute une des dernières
journées mobilisation et moi cette
colère je veux la transformer la
civilité veut la transformer en rapport
de force pour améliorer des résultats
sur le pouvoir d'achat sur
l'amélioration de l'organisation du
travail et des conditions de travail
c'est un élément central du débat qui
n'a malheureusement pas eu lieu sur le
dialogue social sur la revalorisation
des agents publics donc qui souffrent
aujourd'hui de salaire extrêmement bas
et donc j'en appelle il y a un enjeu
vraiment important dans les prochaines
semaines pour éviter le tout ça pour ça
qui pourrait ressortir de 5 mois de
mouvement c'est les futurs négociations
est-ce qu'il y a l'espace puisqu'il y a
eu les bilatérales est-ce qu'il y a un
espace qui s'ouvre pour obtenir
notamment évidemment sur le thème majeur
du moment les hausse de salaire donc je
crois pas forcément public il y en a pas
ça a été assez clair le petit échange
qui a eu avec Elisabeth borne montre
aussi la marche de manœuvre dans
laquelle elle fonctionne et puis
manifestement le thème que vient
d'évoquer Laurent Berger sur la question
du travail était effectivement une
question centrale dans notre société
mais par exemple sur les questions de
santé sécurité le sujet du moment c'est
le bilan des ordonnances Macron de 2017
qui ont par exemple supprimer les CHSCT
les comités Hygiène Sécurité conditions
de travail dans les premiers rapports y
compris officiels qui ont été qui ont
été publiés on voit que ça a des effets
négatifs sur le suivi de ces sujets là
dans les entreprises donc avoir une
négociation là-dessus suppose de revenir
enfin de mettre à plat ses ordonnances
et de revenir sur un certain nombre de
décisions qui ont été prises Emmanuel
Macron a déjà dit que ça c'était le
passé les ordonnances Macron on allait
sûrement pas réouvrir ce genre de
discussion donc si oui je pense qu'avec
les pouvoirs publics il y a peu de il y
a peu de choses à attendre en revanche
l'enjeu vous avez raison il est entre
les syndicats de pouvoir nourrir de
pouvoir élaborer ensemble et que ça soit
des axes de mobilisation bien entendu
tout le monde sait que c'était un peu le
dernier tour de piste sur les retraites
avec la question c'est que pour les gens
la question des retraites elle est pas
digérée parce que il reste toujours avec
deux années de plus y compris les
carrières courtes enfin les carrières
longues ceux qui étaient censé partir
avant il se prennent deux ans plus et ça
je crois que les gens vont pas le
digérer mais la mobilisation en
elle-même c'est sûr qu'elle doit elle
doit changer d'objet elle doit être
réinvestie là-dessus dans les anciens
égales on a entendu aucune voie qui
s'oppose à ça maintenant est-ce qu'ils
vont être capables de nourrir ça
toujours ensemble ce qui serait nouveau
mais c'est peut-être un des acquis de ce
mouvement une des projections de de ce
qui s'est passé ces derniers mois et
puis aussi il faut pas l'oublier c'est
les déclinaisons qu'il va y avoir au
niveau local et dans les entreprises un
exemple
Eurodisney Eurodisney il y a 7-8 ans les
questions de salaire elles se posaient
déjà ils étaient 250 à débrayer maximum
il y a 2000 personnes sur le site là ils
ont il y a plus que ça que ce que je
raconte il y a beaucoup plus que ça sur
le site mais là ils sont 2000 ils sont
prêts entre 16 2000 à débrayé
aujourd'hui dans une espèce de structure
intercy syndicale constituée Haddock
dans lequel les syndicats se retrouvent
très bien mais je pense que les
projections on va voir au niveau local
ce que ça va de il y a beaucoup de
conflits sur les salaires dans les
entreprises et il y a beaucoup de gens
qui ont appris à se connaître au niveau
local à travers
cette logique d'interse d'unité
syndicale elle va se décliner localement
voilà et elle peut avoir des effets de
rapport de force locaux et reconstruire
un tissu de relations sociales avec un
rapport de force qui soit plus tout à
fait celui qu'on connaît depuis 20 à 30
ans mais alors c'est pas la seule
condition d'unité syndicale il faut
aussi qu'ils aillent chercher les
salariés là où ils sont les syndicats
ils sont logés pour l'instant par les
institutions d'ailleurs dans
l'entreprise c'est là qu'on négocie or
aujourd'hui on sait très bien qu'autour
de l'entreprise il y a tout un tas de
sous-traitants de sous-traitants de
sous-traitants etc tous ces
travailleurs-là ils échappent en grande
partie au maillage syndical donc il faut
que les syndicats redéploient leur
structure pour pouvoir véritablement
capitaliser ce qu'ils ont gagné là donc
il y a beaucoup d'efforts à faire mais
je pense que l'Inter syndical est un
capital que aucun ne dispersera en
conséquence parmi les actions marquantes
de cette journée cette coupure du réseau
électrique de tout un quartier dans les
Hauts-de-Seine à Issy-les-Moulineaux
c'est un quartier où il y a énormément
de sièges sociaux de média et
d'entreprises du numérique écouter les
explications du secrétaire général du
syndicat CGT énergie Bagneux qui est à
l'origine de cette action
le message écoutez nous en fait
qu'est-ce qu'il faut pour que vous
compreniez ce qu'on est en train de dire
autour d'une table ça marche pas Sophie
Binet elle parle très bien ça marche pas
c'est un espionner notre secrétaire
général de de fédération il parle on
l'écoute pas les sénateurs de gauche il
parle on l'écoute pas et à un moment
donné il faut juste qu'on vous montre
voilà voilà ce qu'on est capable de
faire et ça c'est encore qu'un
avant-goût on vous avait promis en
langage en vous avez promis Cannes et
ben vous a fait ici le moulino
médiatiquement un peu moins puissant ici
les Moulinaux par rapport à
roland-garrossouka mais bon ça c'est
c'est autre chose je voudrais que qu'on
conclut quand même sur est-ce qu'il y a
pas pour le gouvernement une opportunité
d'entre ouvrir la porte sur autre chose
que les retraites quand même est-ce
qu'il y a pas quelque chose à saisir
Sophie dans
pour retrouver quoi qu'est-ce que pour
justement
ressouder un peu enfin sortir de cette
logique du mur oui mais peut-être
Emmanuel Macron dans son discours au
Mont-Saint-Michel pour essayer de
justement en prendre un peu de hauteur
peut-être un peu d'ampleur pour
contempler de loin la les siècles
turbulents qui passent sous nos yeux
c'est pas une grande négociation sur les
salaires
la difficulté c'est Elisabeth borne elle
a ouvert cette porte c'est un sujet
fédérateur tout le monde est d'accord
oui quatre points
mais pas sur les solutions
et quels sont les marges de manœuvre
d'Emmanuel Macron aujourd'hui du point
de vue que ce soit pour le pouvoir
d'achat parce que pour moi ce qui va
monter c'est effectivement cet été la
question du pouvoir d'achat on le voit
dans les marchés le fruit des le prix
pardon des fruits et légumes mais aussi
évidemment le prix de l'essence qui est
qui a redescendu dans beaucoup de pays
européens depuis la crise ukrainienne et
qui reste très élevé en France et donc
les Français qui ont la chance de
pouvoir partir en vacances cet été vont
le sentir qu'est-ce que peut faire le
Emmanuel Macron tout le monde les
Français me semble-t-il on tentait le
quoi qu'il en coûte du covid et ça ça
reste aussi quelque chose de très
impressionnant dans l'état d'esprit de
l'opinion publique c'est que à un moment
on a pu tout faire et aujourd'hui on a
le sentiment que le gouvernement ne le
fait pas merci beaucoup merci à tous
d'avoir participé à ce débat je vous dis
à bientôt sur public